bonsoir bonsoir à vous deux merci d'être
avec nous pour répondre à des questions
parce que toujours au cours de la
journée
à l'Université de Sherbrooke les
étudiants les maîtrise en fiscalité ont
répondu aux questions du public sur
notre site Web Luc question de marque
physique pour vous qui peut recevoir le
crédit d'impôt prime au travail quels
sont les critères bon c'est une question
assez vaste qui ne peut pas le recevoir
un étudiant à temps plein sauf s'il a un
conjoint ou des enfants à la même
résidence dans ce cas là pour le
recevoir c'est des critères de revenus
faut pour une personne seule gagner au
moins 2400 dollars de revenus de travail
et gagner moins que 21500 c'est ça qui
donne droit à la prime au travail pour
une personne seule pour un couple avec
enfants c'est avoir un revenu de travail
en 3600 et 52000 on parle de revenus
familial net de 52000 pour sortir de la
prime au travail parfait autre question
qui vient de Johan qui dit je suis
proche
mais je ne demeure pas avec eux
puis je demandais le crédit d'impôt pour
être dans Myriam en fait le crédit pour
aidant au niveau du Québec est un crédit
maximum de 1299 dollars auquel on va
appliquer le tout on peut le demander
pour des parents qui n'habitent pas dans
une résidence pour aînée mais il faut
également que la personne soit atteinte
d'une déficience physique ou
graves ou mental mais il faut également
avoir un certificat de médecin qui
prouve que on a le droit à ce crédit-là
l'autre chose c'est qu'au niveau du
fédéral on a également les crédits
canadiens pour et d'un naturel qui
peuvent s'appliquer mais encore là il va
falloir qu'on s'assure que on subit aux
parents que ce soit pas nécessairement
vivant avec eux mais il faut avoir une
implication au niveau du parent c'est
pas parce qu'on leur rend visite une
fois par semaine il faut vraiment avoir
une aide de façon continue au niveau des
parents
c'est ça donc ça va dépendre vraiment de
est-ce qu'on est là présent tous les
jours est-ce qu'on y va de façon
continue donc c'est vraiment une grosse
zone grise mais effectivement on peut le
demander mais il faut vraiment que ça
soit comme on dit là qu'on se souvient
au niveau nourriture logement habitation
donc habituellement on a les parents
chez nous pour avoir le droit ce
crédit-là mais si on habite pas avec eux
mais qu'on peut prouver qu'on se
souvient là ça pourrait être faisable
Serge marchand demande ceci est-ce qu'un
don à notre enfant pour l'achat d'une
maison et déductible d'impôts au Luc un
don en espèces ce n'est pas déductible
pour leur apparent et c'est sans
conséquence fiscale pour l'enfant donc
ce n'est pas imposable également donc
c'est quand même assez simple c'est tout
c'est tout d'accord voilà c'est clair
monsieur marchand voilà on a on a rien à
ajouter là-dessus Diane roi dit
j'aimerais savoir quel est l'impact du
revenu des enfants à charge sur l'impôt
des parents et les allocations
familiales en fait faut savoir que les
allocations familiales sont calculées
sur le revenu des parents et non des
enfants donc familial ou canadienne au
niveau du fédéral ne seront pas impactés
par contre ce qui va être impacté c'est
les crédits haute que les parents ont
que ça soit l'équivalent pour personne
entièrement à charge que ça soit les
crédits de scolarité qu'on transfert aux
parents eux vont être impactés parce que
chaque revenu qu'on gagne ou un enfant
ne pourra pas transférer les crédits de
scolarité à ses parents avant d'avoir
absorbé l'entièreté de sa facture
d'impôts donc il y a d'autres crédits
qui vont être impactés mais pas les
allocations familiales ok parfait voilà
pour cette question on y va avec une
autre question de Jean-Yves Naulette qui
demande ceci qui dit j'ai 78 ans quel
avantage pourrais-je avoir si je
retourne au travail et est-ce que je
pourrais contribuer à nouveau à Montréal
pour un salaire dans les six chiffres un
salaire d'investis chiffres à 78 ans
c'est très bien oui mais malheureusement
ça lui enlève le droit d'avoir le crédit
pour la prolongation de carrière car le
crédit prolongation de carrière c'est
pour les gens de 60 ans et plus à 78 ans
tu as droit en autant que tu gagnes un
revenu de travail en 5000 et disons
70000 passer 70000 c'est avant les six
chiffres je pensais ça tu as plus droit
et c'est ça je crois qu'il demandait
aussi s'il y avait droit de venir dans
son réel dans son réel dans son réel
malheureusement passer 72 ans peut pas
cotiser à son réel ce n'est pas possible
il a été transformé en fer la seule
façon de cotiser un réel c'est d'avoir
une conjointe de moins de 72 ans on
pourrait cotiser au réel de sa conjointe
une bonne
suggestionnant le crédit pour frais
médicaux au fédéral comment ça
fonctionne doit-on consigner chaque
transaction dans notre déclaration de
revenus au par chant d'expertise si nous
accédons le montant maximal autorisé
est-ce qu'un logiciel nous corrige ou
nous devons le calculer nous-même sans
excédent Myriam en fait je vais faire un
petit survol rapidement parce qu'il y a
plusieurs côtés à cette question d'abord
il faut savoir qu'il y a une portion de
crédit médicaux qui est non remboursable
et au fédéral et au Québec et après ça
il y a des crédits qui sont
remboursables qui sont en fonction des
revenus au niveau des demandes de frais
médicaux moi je dis souvent à mes
clients amenez-moi pas tous les petits
reçus ce que moi je conseille c'est que
si vous avez des assurances mettez le
sommaire des assurances avec l'ensemble
des dépenses qu'on a mis par contre il
faut savoir que ce n'est pas parce que
l'assurance ne le couvre pas que ça ne
rentre pas dans les frais médicaux et
vice c'est pas parce que ça ne rentre
pas les assurances le rembourse
automatiquement c'est acceptable donc il
faut vraiment faire un petit jeu de voir
quelles sont les les frais qui est sans
remboursables faut savoir aussi que les
frais médicaux exemple pour les lunettes
son maxi certainement entend au niveau
de du gouvernement ce qui est pas
nécessairement le cas de toutes les
assurances ou encore l'orthodontie les
frais de dentistes ne sont pas
acceptables au niveau de certaines
assurances mais ce sont des frais
médicaux quand même donc c'est un bon
point de départ de partir avec ce qui
n'a pas été remboursé par l'assurance et
faire des ajustements question de Denis
Caron est-ce que les coûts liés au
vaccin contre le zona peuvent faire
partie des frais médicaux Luc ça rentre
dans les frais médicaux oui et bonne
nouvelle dans le dernier budget du
Québec donc à partir de du budget là
pour 2023 suivant le vaccination zona
sera défrayé par le gouvernement donc ça
va devenir gratuit et donc ça ne rentre
plus dans les frais médicaux
donc à partir de maintenant à partir de
maintenant techniquement il y avait pas
la date mais il y a un des sommes
consacrées la vaccination gratuite du
zona dans le budget du Québec excellente
nouvelle une dernière question de yon
molosnick j'ai une assurance avec mon
employeur qui couvre ma famille le
logiciel d'impôt ne me permet pas
d'inclure les frais médicaux payés pour
mon fils de 20 ans qui ne sont pas
remboursés par l'assurance j'aimerais
savoir s'il peut inclure les frais dans
sa déclaration ici ou si d'autres
options existent j'ai oublié de
m'enseigné tantôt par exemple pour les
logiciels effectivement il maximise
l'ensemble des dépenses pour qu'est-ce
qui est remboursable non remboursements
en fonction des revenus donc pour
répondre à Monsieur onyx ce qui arrive
c'est que les frais médicaux qu'on a
payé pour notre enfant doivent aller
dans notre déclaration par contre il y a
une section différente pour les
personnes à charge de plus de 18 ans
dans lequel on va pouvoir calculer le
crédit parce qu'il va tenir compte des
revenus de son fils OK et par la suite
il pourra le réclamer pour ça s'ajouter
mais il pourra pas la mettre dans la
même section que sa conjointe les
enfants mineurs Myriam vous restez avec
nous on vous retrouverez en fin
d'émission au lieu que je vous remercie
merci pour tout d'ailleurs vraiment
c'est une belle collaboration cette
émission n'est pas terminée merci Luc il
y a pas de quoi la prochaine pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI